[Music]
good morning and welcome to the first
trevor phillips on sunday of 2022.
i'd love to be able to say a happy new
year to you but it's just hours since we
learned that the toll of covert deaths
in the uk has passed
150 000
for many viewers this year will have
begun on anything but a happy note and
as of this morning there is no question
the biggest story in town remains the
battle against covid
but the virus isn't the only issue
roiling the political landscape with
looming tax rights energy price hikes
and the threat of inflation stalking the
land i reckon we'll also be worrying
away at the prospects for the economy in
the weeks to come
abroad brexit clearly isn't done yet and
i think we can count on vladimir putin
to keep us interested in foreign affairs
while here at home after a court verdict
on the colston 4 in bristol we have our
own wars already in progress the culture
wars as they're being called
so plenty to keep us busy for the next
60 minutes and a stellar lineup today to
tackle those touchy topics
it's the first week of term in
westminster and in schools up and down
the country so appropriately enough i'll
be joined by the education secretary
nadim zahawi
with millions of people worried about
upcoming big rises and tax and energy
prices we'll hear what labour would do
from shadow chancellor rachel reeves
there's a stark difference in approaches
to covered between england and the other
nations of the uk so we'll talk to
welshman first minister mark drakeford
london was the first part of the uk to
be hit hard by omicron so we'll try to
get a clearer picture of the state of
covert in the capital and what it means
for the rest of the country from public
health director for london professor
kevin fenton
it's the impact of omicron on the nhs
that's the biggest concern with months
of winter ahead so we'll speak to
professor dame ann johnson president of
the academy of medical sciences
but as i said there's more than covid to
talk about liz trust now runs
negotiation with the eu over brexit
arrangements in northern ireland and
says she'll invoke article 16 if the eu
doesn't compromise so we'll hear from
ambassador to the uk joao valle de
almeida and earlier this week
four people who pulled down the bristol
statue of slave trader edward colston
were cleared by a jury with politicians
from all sides weighing in
but what do bristolians think i'll talk
to the city's mayor marvin reese
but first i'm joined by the education
secretary nadim zahari good morning
secretary of state
can we just start with the um state of
play
yesterday
150
000
deaths looking back
can we really say
that all of those deaths were
unavoidable
well of course
we will learn the lessons of how
we dealt with the pandemic through the
inquiry that we've announced
and
that is the right way to do this
one of those 150 000 was my uncle he was
eligible for a vaccine
sadly
he contracted covert before we could get
him
vaccinated so then um we had to wait for
that period but unfortunately
it became very severe and we lost him uh
to this uh evil virus
so it you know it brings it home to me
um and to many families that you know
150 000 are not just
numbers statistics they are parents
grandparents uncles aunts
um husbands wives um so it is important
that we learn those lessons and that
inquiry will be able to deliver that in
the meantime
we continue to deal with uh this virus
with omicron which is a you know the
infection rates are a quantum higher
than delta
but thankfully the booster seems to be
working incredibly well
and you look at the
although the number of people going into
hospital is rising still but actually
the people on icu
has been coming down which
again demonstrates that the vaccines are
the best way out of this pandemic
because they again weaken the link
between infection rates and severe
infection of course hospitalization and
death uh thankfully so
90
of um over 12 year olds now have had a
single uh vaccine which is great to see
that uptake and vaccine hesitancy
decreasing including of course over the
christmas period many people have never
been vaccinated came forward to be
actually and 90 over 50s have had a
booster and so um i'm confident that the
the
way out of this and as we transition
this virus from pandemic to endemic i
hope will be one of the first you ask me
the question how well we've performed i
hope will be one of the first major
economies to demonstrate to the world
how you transition from pandemic to
endemic and then deal with this however
long it remains with us with the five
six seven ten years
i want to unpack that but just before we
leave the 150 000 figure
there will be families like your own
who
they will
i won't say look forward but they will
be anticipating the inquiry
but your relatives and families like
yours
probably already know that and this is
not pointing the finger but they
probably didn't already know
that much of what we did was too little
too late wasn't it
i don't agree with that and if you look
at my role in this with the vaccine uh
deployment oh the success well but also
we've
we've had many successes um so one of
the the big successes now obviously is
the antivirals and uh uh javid the
health secretary has ordered over five
million antivirals um of course the
success is testing we've tested um you
know twice as many people in the uk than
france has done i think about four times
and germany has done over the past uh uh
two years we've done 400 million plus
tests if i tell you that in january
alone uh we've ordered 425 million um
lateral flow devices um people can get
their test schools
opened uh last week we are secondary
schools to test at school we got 31
million kits delivered because i got
them to order
from november and we had a different um
supply chain for schools we're gonna get
another 17.6 million out
by this week and so there's many
successes in terms of our diagnostics uh
capability we had
not much diagnosis capability to speak
of in the uk now we are a behemoth when
it comes to testing diagnosis and of
course uh vaccination not just for the
uk but rest of the world as well let's
let's talk about where we go from here
you have already said this morning that
you think that we are moving from
pandemic to endemic let's talk about
some of the signals of that
when do you want the isolation period to
move from seven days to five days
so the uk health and uh security agency
um did a very good blog on this and your
viewers should actually have a look at
that and um what they looked at is
because people said you know the
america's at five days why are we at
seven days actually we begin our
isolation period when people get
symptoms
in the u.s it's when they test positive
so we have to be careful
um as to whether we move because what
you could end up as an is actually a a
perverse incentive where the
spike
is higher because people come out of
isolation too early but they said they
will review it and if the evidence is
there where if you are asymptomatic and
you are vaccinated and boosted and you
have two uh days uh consecutive days of
negative lateral flow tests uh they said
they will keep keep that under review of
course it would help um i want that to
happen
as soon as possible well i would
obviously always defer to the scientific
advice on this it would certainly um you
know help mitigate some of the pressures
on uh
you know schools on critical workforce
and others but i would absolutely be um
driven by the advice from the experts
the scientists on whether we should move
to uh five days from seven days uh
otherwise what you don't want is
obviously to create um the the wrong
outcome by higher levels of infection
well you want that to happen another uh
suggestion that's uh apparently coming
forward and i think you
are associated with this that um
lateral flow tests at some point gonna
have to stop being free
uh if this is a
an endemic condition
when do you want that to happen i saw
that story this morning which i was
slightly puzzled by because i don't
recognize it at all this is absolutely
not where we are at on the contrary i've
just said to you in my opening remarks
that you know for january alone we've
got 425 million latin flow tests coming
in and they'll continue to be
available for free because actually
we've got three lines of defense the
booster and obviously vaccination if you
haven't been vaccinated
testing and antivirals and all those
three things are really so i don't
really recognize where that story's
coming to be clear there are no plans at
the moment absolutely not to
stop lateral flow tests being free
absolutely not um
the former former head of the vaccine
tax force task force says that we should
end
the mass vaccination campaign uh after
this booster round and move to
something called normality do you think
that's right third booster and then we
treat this like normal annual flu well
one of the you know actually real great
things we have in the uk is people like
clive dix who you're referring to and of
course kate bingham and um uh
richard sykes who's now chairing the
vaccines task force and others who are
brilliant brits who are world experts in
this area so i would certainly look at
the evidence all i would say is actually
we know
that the booster campaign has worked
incredibly well in terms of preventing
infection but also in preventing
hospitalization um and so we want to
continue with that i would obviously you
know look at what the jcvi would say on
this uh for future variants because we
are going to have to live with this
virus it will um deliver other variants
this year next year and beyond and i
think the great thing is vaccines are
getting better so we're getting you know
uh uh polyvalent multi-veil of vaccines
and that will uh deliver
greater protection against many other
variants of the virus as well as of
course the antiviral so we will continue
to improve
live with it that's that's the future um
you're painting a pretty optimistic
picture this morning but
let's be clear from the amd wards of our
hospitals it doesn't quite look like
that ambulances are having to wait to
move patients into
uh bed you're bringing military
personnel in
to help health leaders saying they could
be 25 down in staff numbers
staff absence tripled since the
beginning of december the truth is
the system is already pretty near
collapse and that's today's problem
rather than the sunday uploads of
tomorrow isn't it so
the first thing to say on that is the
ambulance units and we've got 4 000 now
i think a 500
increase on what we had pre-covered
um
the nhs front line the nhs support staff
have done a tremendous job if you look
at
the
absolutely so they are under pressure
because obviously of the uh um
quantum higher infection rates with
omicron versus delta and therefore that
seven day isolation period um uh
associated with that but if you look at
the number of uh hospital trusts that
have declared a critical incident
there's 24. indeed right which a lot
that is that is about 130 plus hospital
trust out of that there's 24.
in 2017-18 23
hospital trust declared a critical
incident so it is a mechanism that the
nhs uses very well
in
times of very high pressure on the
system
the nhs is very good uh because they've
got this ability to digital passport
staff between trusts that's also capable
we are
launching um eight nightingale um sites
uh we are probably going beyond that
increased capacity as well there are now
ten thousand plus getting the additional
nurses in the nhs i'm four thousand plus
additional doctors getting
yes
what i'm putting to you however is that
there are doctors who are saying we're
on our knees
there are nurses who are saying
the shifts are uh not that we're
depleted in each shift there are people
who are saying that actually
we're not getting treatments because and
there are we've
skye had report done reports people who
have lost relatives because of the
crisis in hospitals now you can tell me
all the things that you're doing but the
point is actually the more you tell me
that you're doing the more i wonder if
it's enough because actually if you're
doing all of this and we're still having
this situation
there's a crisis aren't you being a bit
complacent not at all it is a as as sad
as javelin said it is a a rocky few
weeks i would say this is a a really
tough time that's that is that is
absolutely right because obviously we've
got people who are absent because of uh
having to self-isolate but what we're
doing is doing everything we can to make
sure that the nhs has the ability uh to
ride out this uh
bump in the road for uh the virus
within that is the additional five
billion for just the six months of uh uh
money being made available by the
chancellor richie sunak to help the nhs
uh weather this storm and that's the
right thing to do including by the way
for example
in one week we've had um
overseas nurses very something like 900
overseas nurses registered in one week
so we know that there are staffing
pressures but we're trying to mitigate
against them by recruiting more nurses
50 000 over this uh parliament um all
right let me come and of course the
military helping okay other parts
let me come back to your own particular
responsibility um you're sending
ventilator kits to schools you've
mandated masks but you're not going to
know the effect of the return
are you sure you've done as much
as you could do
we are continuing to monitor the
situation so what we did was before uh
uh
christmas we made sure
schools
ordered their kits for the testing
before that
in november we got 350 000 co2 monitors
at the cost of 25 million pounds so that
we can monitor the atmosphere in the
classrooms from that data we're able to
model to say actually we need about 8
000 air purifiers for those
classrooms that need that you know the
help that they can't mitigate um
for making sure the air is circulated
and fresh in the classroom we're getting
those out
this coming week obviously we prioritize
special uh schools and schools in
alternative provision because those kids
are the most vulnerable and of course as
of monday we continue the school
vaccination program do you feel assured
we're not going to have to send children
home or close close schools so i will do
everything in my power i was at
hammersmith academy uh last week and i
saw how brilliant they did with testing
their pupils and getting back to
education school leaders
teachers by the way the support staff
and a big shout out for the support
staff because without them we couldn't
do any of this i'm confident we'll be
able to cope with that um
no but uh but i do want to talk to you
about the economy because of course that
is actually yes for most people the
thing that is um looming
um it's not looking great most people
are going to see
an actual cut in the in their take home
in april because of tax rises
we are likely to see an energy price
rise could be anything up to several
hundred pounds
a month for the average household and
right behind that woof inflation coming
down the track
why don't you reconsider as i think some
of your cabinet colleagues want the rise
in national insurance because the cost
of living is going to be catastrophic
rise could be catastrophic so let me
just pull you up on your first sentence
the the uk economy because of the action
we took
over covert and how we've cope with
omicron is going to be one of the
fastest growing economies in the g20
yeah yeah we can all we can have an
argument about gdp numbers what i want
to talk to you about is household
budgets
and what people feel like right and so
what's the best way for for people to
cope with
the cost of living is to have a job
right we have the highest level of
employment um
this is a great this is a great this is
a great answer but i'm talking to you
about people who have jobs yes but they
who are going to find that there are
hundreds of pounds coming out of their
packet because of your tax rises deal
with that right so allow me to finish
that point so who were those people
those people are the people on universal
credit right they're
the average household yes a lot of whom
are in jobs yes not in receipts of
benefits yes they will feel the tax rise
and the price prices how why not deal
with that okay so the national living
wage going up to 9 pounds 50 in april
same time right the universal credit
taper does make a difference about a
thousand pounds for those who who are
probably finding it most difficult uh to
cope the energy price cap remains in
place half a billion pounds to local
government because they know which
families need the most help with those
utility bills half a billion pounds
going to them as well as the winter fuel
allowance which is a 140 pound rebate
that will rise to 150 pound in october
taking more people it was it takes 2.2
million people 2.7 million people in
october people who you're not talking
about people are in work look
can they work why wouldn't they we we we
have we're in work trevor we we we have
we
we we're we're coming to the end of this
but uh and i you know we can talk around
this uh a lot but
isn't the fundamental problem here that
your chancellor
doesn't appear to have a plan to
uh ease the pressure on household
budgets i know you can talk about the
people who are at the margins and so on
but the average household is what i'm
asking about the business secretary
doesn't seem to have a new plan to
support businesses ravaged by covert no
furlough or anything like that um
you you
i don't know what you're going to do
about sick teachers but the point is the
government doesn't really feel like it's
got a plan to deal with this cost of
living crisis uh prime minister seems to
be saying put my hands together and then
pray no not true i tell you for what you
asked me about the nic right let's look
at that right
now we know that that 36 billion
is absolutely the right thing to do to
deal with adult social care and the and
the backlog of the nhs right
who's paying for it 14
of the highest earners pay 50 of that
rise 6.6 million of those who really are
right at the bottom of earning
pay nothing
for the nic okay so it's worth putting
in perspective it is as progressive as
you can be whilst delivering on adult
social care and the backlog of the nhs
that makes sense okay secretary the
business secretary is meeting literally
all the time to deal with the energy
spike in gas prices i'm sorry i'm gonna
have to stop you because uh we have
other guests waiting and i am sure you
and i are gonna have this conversation
many times in coming weeks thank you for
your time this morning thank you
now let's go to hear labour's take on
all of this the shadow chancellor rachel
reeves joins me from central london
good morning shadow chancellor um
i'm going to come to you on the things
i've been discussing with the education
sector in a second but you said this
morning that your big plan
to deal with this cost of living crisis
is a windfall tax on north sea oil and
gas producers how's that going to work
in a declining industry
and one which basically isn't producing
much in the way of profits at the moment
anyway
well we've had 10 years more than a
decade of dither and delay and
incompetence from this government which
is why we have this energy price crisis
today of course prices have gone up
globally but we are uniquely exposed in
britain because of the decisions of this
government it's a failure to regulate
properly to get rid of our gas storage
and a failure to retrofit homes and to
go with the speed on new nuclear and
renewables that are necessary and that's
why today i'm putting up forward a
package of measures to keep bills down
this april to help families and
pensioners who are struggling with this
cost of living crisis that is coming in
april and it is right to ask those who
have benefited from high higher gas and
oil prices to pay more into the system
and that's why i'm putting forward a
one-off increase in the taxes paid by
north sea oil and gas they are likely to
make record profits
this year because of that spike in
prices let's tax them a bit more and use
that money to reduce bills for ordinary
people who are struggling so much at the
moment and we estimate that um just
because of the higher
prices already the oil and gas industry
in the north sea are likely to pay 2.3
billion pounds more in tax a one-off
windfall tax will raise an additional
1.2 billion pounds let's put that money
into keeping bills lower for everybody
else
okay with respect to senator chancellor
um
it's okay for you to say that they're
having a terrific time uh because of
this the temporary spike in oil price uh
oil prices but from those in the
industry who actually have to pay the
bills they are saying that it hasn't
particularly helped them and actually
things are going pretty much south so
how do you respond to their view that
actually
it may help somebody but it certainly
isn't helping them and that what you
might be doing is preparing for the
decimation of our energy sector
well chancellors have used this device
before of increasing taxes on north sea
oil and gas when revenues and profits
are particularly high the previous
chancellor george osborne did it in 2011
gordon brown and before him margaret
thatcher also
increased taxes for a short period of
time on north sea oil and gas when
prices were particularly high and those
windfall profits were being made at any
chancellor any shadow chancellor has to
make choices about where to tax and
where to spend i want to tax fairly and
spend wisely but when those excess
profits are being made it does make
sense to have a win full tax and use
that money to keep bills down for
everybody else because unless action is
taken and taken soon
millions of families and pensioners
across the country
are staring into a huge cost of living
crisis as you said earlier trevor an
increase in national insurance at the
same time that gas and electricity bills
are going to explode potentially up by
700 pounds a year for bill payers but i
we cannot stand by as the government are
currently doing and allowing those price
increases to go ahead when action can be
taken now to reduce bills especially for
those who are the squeeze middle on
lower incomes a pensioner families
as well action has to be taken taken to
avert this crisis that is coming down
the line okay just one more chance on
this i'm not going to argue with you
about the nature of the problem i'm
talking i'm asking about the nature of
the solution um
you are
projecting a windfall tax on a declining
industry reserves are declining which
already says it's squeezed and actually
they um
that though the big oil companies are
going elsewhere to develop are you are
you happy to
project a plan which essentially will uh
will
make britain more dependent on energy
supplies from others for example mr
putin's got lots of oil and gas
are you happy that we are
making him smile this morning by saying
we might have to depend more on him
plan my plan trevor is the exact
opposite we need to wean ourselves off
imported gas from russia and qatar and
elsewhere and that's why in the plan
that i'm setting out today is also a big
boost in investment in renewables and in
nuclear in our hydrogen industry so we
are not reliant that is why the uk is
uniquely exposed because the government
got rid of the gas reserves has dithered
and delayed for over a decade on new
nuclear and in investment in renewables
and as a result we are particularly
exposed to that imported gas from
countries like russia who do have us
over a barrel and that is why as well as
a short-term action to keep prices down
we've got to retrofit homes speed up
that investment in new nuclear and
renewables and ensure that we are never
in this position again because i said as
i say the uk is uniquely exposed to
these rising gas prices because of a
failure for over a decade now by this
government to take action and that's why
kia stammer and myself working with ed
miliband our shadow secretary of state
for climate and net zero have put
forward this balanced package of
measures to keep prices low by asking
those who are making big profits this
year to pay more into the system for
this one year only
forgive me i i know it's it's it's a bit
tricky because of the technicalities to
dave uh that you can't him hear me
interrupting but forgive me interrupting
you but the other part of your plan is
to cut vat on uh energy
bills um that's a bit odd for a labor
shadow chancellor isn't it because that
would be
uh benefit richer households relative to
poorer households why not just simply uh
go straight to the tax system i mean
that would be a progressive step rather
than a regressive way of dealing with
the problem
i'm setting out today three things to
keep bills low first of all a cut in vat
on gas and electricity bills from five
percent to zero for one year uh saving
uh households given the price rise we're
expected to see a hundred pounds a year
the second thing is smoothing the some
of the costs of the increase that we're
likely to see in april to take a further
100 pounds of bills but recognizing that
it is those on lower incomes families
and pensioners as well as well as those
who uh the squeezed middle uh who are
struggling with those rising bills and
rising tax putting extra support through
the warms homes discount to ensure that
those people get the help that is needed
an extra 400 pounds off their bills from
april uh this year to help them through
this difficult time with the prices high
and you'll know trevor that the prime
minister was the biggest advocate for
cutting vat on gas and electricity bills
during the european referendum but now
when cutting those bills would make more
difference than ever the prime minister
says no well i say that bills can't be
paid on broken promises the government
should honor that commitment that the
prime minister made to take vat of gas
and electricity prices if this isn't the
time to do it then frankly i don't know
when is
it it's a bit odd um rachel ruiz to to
hear you saying uh you want to follow a
boris johnson policy and i don't think
you've quite dealt with my question
about whether this is not
a regressive uh tax on households and
wouldn't
a labor approach be to
uh impose a more progressive tax so that
you're not putting a relatively higher
burden on the low paid you can do all
the other things that you've mentioned i
i hear all that but this particular
cut would mean that better off
households benefit relative to the poor
why are you doing that
well in fact it is poorer households who
spend a higher proportion of their
spending on gas and electricity bills
and that's particularly so for pensioner
households who are at home more and need
to keep their homes warm so i don't buy
this idea that cutting vat is somehow a
regressive policy but we are making sure
that through this package of measures
we're announcing today and the windfall
tax on those excess profits of north sea
oil and gas are used particularly to
benefit those people on lower incomes
families and pensioners with additional
support for the warm homes discount so
support for all with that cut in vat but
extra support for those who need it most
that is the progressive thing to do but
it also recognizes that everybody right
now is facing through no fault of their
own big increases in prices in april
government can do something about it
they must choose to act because without
action a combination of national
insurance increases council tax
increases and this catastrophe of higher
domestic gas and electricity bills will
be a disaster for families and
pensioners in just a couple of months
time
radar reeves thank you very much for
your time this morning
thank you
now the nations of the united kingdom
have gone their separate ways when it's
come to responding to the threat posed
by the omicron variant scotland northern
ireland and wales have imposed more
stringent restrictions while in england
boris johnson says he hopes to ride it
out under current plan b rules
the welsh first minister mark drakeford
has been withering in his criticism of
the approach in england he called it an
i called england an outlier that doesn't
take the action needed to protect its
own population
while he joins me now
good morning first minister um
do you think that uh
wales is in some way in danger from um
from england's policies
well i've agreed with the prime minister
uh many times that it is better to have
single messages across the united
kingdom that that allows us to
communicate the seriousness of the
position and the measures we ask
individual citizens to take in their own
lives so when we have different messages
across our border that does make it more
difficult for us but we face this in the
past we go on doing as we see it the
right thing to protect lives and
livelihoods here in wales
um first minister wales currently has a
higher incidence of covid despite uh the
restrictions um
surely surely
uh
well first of all explain why why is
that the case
well actually i think it's a misleading
comparison
because there are parts of wales which
are much lower than other parts of wales
and parts of wales which are much lower
than the hot spots in england so
comparing the whole of wales and the
whole of england simply doesn't get to
where the real nub of the issue lies
we are trying to make sure that we
protect wales from the onslaught of the
omicron variant which has moved uh east
to west coming into wales later than in
parts of england
our rates are still lower than english
hot spots and we'd like to do our very
best to keep it that way
well it's a little unfair then to
criticize the english if you are saying
that
whale the situation in wales is varied
as it is in england it's a bit unfair to
criticize um
the government in england isn't it
well look the point i make is simply
this i'm asked time after time
why isn't wales doing the same things as
england
and my answer was to point out that in
this debate it is not wales that is the
outlier
wales is following the same path of
putting protections in place that is
being followed by scotland northern
ireland and not just devolved
governments in the united kingdom but
governments across europe and across the
world
the questions as to why
the uk government has decided not to
follow that course of action are for
them to answer not for me
i think they have not done what the
science would have told them they should
do but that's decisions for them to
answer for i'm answerable for the
decisions we take here in wales
on wales itself how long do you want
restrictions to
be held in place and do you
have a plan potentially to increase
those uh restrictions
well first of all we want the
restrictions to be in place for a
shorter time as possible
there is a little bit of good news in
that the modeling we have shows a very
steep rise in omicron cases and we're
not at the top of that wave yet but once
we get to the top the modelling shows a
relatively rapid decline from that peak
as well
so as soon as we are in a position to
see the peak past and the position
improving of course we will want to
revert to the far the more modest level
of protections we had in place only a
few weeks ago
we're hopeful that the level of
protections we currently have in place
will be sufficient
to mitigate the impact of omicron to
help our nhs to deal with the
astonishing pressures which it's having
to deal with every day
and we announced on friday that the
current level of protections will remain
in place for the next week
you're sounding quite optimistic um when
when do you think you might then start
to ease the restrictions in wales
because um i think you yourself have
said and some of your colleagues have
pointed to the absolute uh not
devastation but the serious impact on
the world economy
of those restrictions
well can i just make this point i
completely reject the way in which uk
ministers very often try to play the
economy off against the needs of public
health if we don't attend to the public
health needs the economy is simply
affected in a different way
because we see very large numbers of
people unable to be in work not
confident to go out shopping or to
restaurants and so on so the measures we
take to protect public health are
exactly the measures that protect the
economy now our modeling shows that
within about
but two weeks we will begin to pass the
peak and then as we come down and we're
confident we're coming down that's when
we will look to begin to move back in
the current protections so we might
expect some new news in a couple of
weeks can i ask you very quickly one
last question about a specific situation
uh sky news is reporting uh yesterday
that uh
the non-league english um football club
scott chester could go out of business
because uh its stadium is in wales and
officials are targeting them over
possible
um
rule breaches um
will the welsh government step in to try
to sort this out help chester
uh stay alive
well i've already asked my senior
officials to have discussions today
uh with the police with the club with
the local authority that owns the ground
the chester local authority i'm sure
there is a sensible pragmatic solution
here that doesn't mean that the club is
placed in jeopardy but doesn't result in
the law being broken either
mark drakeford thank you so much for
your time this morning
london's been the front line of the
omicron crisis uh huge numbers of
infections thousands of nhs and other
public service staff of sick
and now the military being sent in to
support overstretched hospitals
but it's also where we might just be
starting to see a glimmer of light at
the end of the tunnel with talk of us
reaching or even getting past the peak
of new cases and hospital admissions
let's try to find out what's happening
in the capital and what it means for the
rest of the country
professor kevin fenton is the public
health regional director for london good
morning professor fenton
good morning good morning travel
has um
the omicron wave
reached its peak in london
well we think we may have passed or are
at the peak data from the ons suggests
that the peak may have occurred at or
just about the new year period and we're
seeing reductions in overall case rates
across the city and the prevalence of
infection within the community but
remember that infection levels are still
very very high and the ons figures
suggest that nearly one in ten londoners
are still infected with the uh with the
with the disease so it means that we're
not yet out of this critical phase of
the pandemic although we may well be
past the peak
but um what we do know is that you
probably have more data than anybody
else um and you can probably tell us
more about omicron itself is it correct
as people now seem to be saying that the
evidence suggests that it's milder and
that the it will come
and go faster than delta
yes i mean when we looked at the data
from south africa we saw the sort of
explosive growth and then the
rapid reductions in infection we're not
yet seeing the rapid reductions in
infection levels in the city but what we
have seen over the past few few weeks is
that as we've gone through the pandemic
we have seen significant numbers of
people becoming infected a lot of
pressure on our general beds
in hospitals across london but
thankfully less pressure on our icu beds
and the reason we've seen that trevor is
because of the high levels of
vaccination that we have across the city
and the most pressure that we have are
from people who are unvaccinated or
incompletely vaccinated and that's where
we're seeing the pressure on the
hospital systems and that's why we're
putting so much effort across the city
to getting people vaccinated getting
their boosters even if they haven't been
vaccinated to this point
i want to come back to this question of
um the unvaccinated in a second but
let's um just take for a moment if we
may with the
position of the nhs um i know nobody can
absolutely predict this but is it your
feeling that london's hospitals will be
able to cope this winter
well it certainly is our hope we are
seeing a slowing down in the rate of
increase of patients with covert being
admitted to london hospitals and that's
really good news but as you said at the
top of the story there are other
pressures that we're facing currently
across our health system in the city so
for example we have relatively higher
staff sickness absence rates which some
of which are from uh covert but there
may be other respiratory illnesses which
are also causing challenges as well and
of course we have the usual winter
pressures which we see as we move
through january and february and as we
emerge from the new year period we're
seeing more people presenting to our
hospital services with the sort of heart
disease the the things that we would
normally see in the winter so there's
three things covered staff sickness
absence as well as winter pressures
means that for the hospitals in london
we're still in a critical phase
i think you've recently uh picked out a
specific thing and said that you're
worried about the rising number of cases
amongst the over 60s in london do you
think
that's a particular issue and will it
lead to more hospitalizations and
serious cases uh of covid
yeah so that's the great point and we're
watching it really really carefully what
we've learned from waves one and waves
two is that the what's one of the
strongest predictors of your likelihood
of hospitalization is being in that over
60 age group and of course if you're
unvaccinated and as the rates are
continuing to increase in that age we're
looking really carefully at the
pressures that it's placing on our
systems thankfully we have very high
rates of vaccination and booster
coverage in our over 60s in london so
we're hoping that even if we're seeing
increasing infections that it will
translate into significant pressures in
our hospitals and especially in icu beds
and this really is the power of the
vaccinations that we have trouble
because it really does prevent severe
disease and death from omicron and all
other variants of the virus
well that takes us actually to the point
you made earlier on which is about the
unvaccinated um
for the last
six or seven months or so health
officials like yourself have been
telling us there needs to be a process
of education and so on well
actually what we're probably now seeing
is that there is a hardcore of people
who say i know all about it i just don't
want to have it i mean
pierce corbin the leader of
the anti-vaxx movement in london is not
an uneducated man he's an astrophysicist
and a phd he understands the science he
just doesn't want to have it what is
your plan to deal with those who are
literally
convinced
sincere anti-vaxxers
well we must remember trevor that that
segment of the population is very very
very small the people who are sort of uh
very strong anti-vaxxer
who hold those views
for the vast majority of londoners we
know that there are three reasons why
people don't get vaccinated the first is
that you know it's an issue of
convenience and access and their ability
to navigate the system you know many
londoners may not have english as their
first language so we have to do the work
of going into communities engaging with
those
individuals and ensuring that we have
good access to the vaccines another
reason in london is that many especially
our younger people may have become
infected with the virus during the
course of the pandemic and so they may
feel less inclined to take the vaccine
because they believe they're already
protected because they've been exposed
and for this group we're ensuring that
we have strong messages about the power
of the vaccination combined with prior
infection to help to protect you moving
forward so these are other reasons why
people aren't getting the vaccines and i
think we need to focus on those and work
with those individuals and communities
rather than trying to convince people
who are absolutely
not willing to take the vaccine
professor fenton thank you so much
thank you thank you
dozens of nhs trusts across the uk have
declared critical incidents as growing
kobe coveted admissions and widespread
staff sickness stretch hospitals to
their limits
so just how tough is it for health
service staff right now what could the
rest of the winter look like as the
system struggles to in the prime
minister's words ride the wave of
omicron
professor daymond johnson is president
of the academy of medical scientists
good morning
professor johnson um
looking at the position nationally i've
just been talking to
uh kevin fenton uh in london we're
looking at the position nationally how
far do you think we are into this
omicron wave
well it's important to note that there's
been big variability across the country
we saw this wave arrive first in london
and if we look across the rest of the
country uh the rates of infection are
still increasing in all areas except
london you heard from kevin fenton that
there may be some slowing in london
we're not seeing that elsewhere so other
parts of the country are still uh not um
are still seeing rises and we don't know
how far that's going to continue that
said rates in london are still higher
than in the rest of the country
the um health centre says that
we don't need boosters
um
or a second booster i beg your pardon do
you agree with that
well i think there's very good news
coming from the ukhsa this week and also
from the joint
the considerations of the joint
committee on vaccinations and what
they've shown now with new data is that
we look at people who've had the booster
who are over 65 and are now three months
from their booster what we're seeing is
that the boosters are holding up in
terms of greatly reducing the risk of
having to be admitted into hospital and
that's a really important result
even though we know that people three
months beyond the boost have less
protection from getting infected
nevertheless they retain the protection
from having been admitted to hospitals
so that's a very important result but
obviously this will be kept under review
as we get more data moving forward
an important
issue here is how people behave and how
they respond to the information that's
put out there now i've just been talking
to
as you heard kevin fenton and he was
saying young people who feel that
they've
had the had covered think that to some
extent they're immune they don't need to
be bothered with the vaccination and so
on um
what more broadly people
i now believing and there's some
evidence that omicron is less severe
than delta
are you worried at all that what's now
going to happen is that people might be
less cautious because they think to some
extent were coming out of the woods
well i think it's very important that we
recognize that people have substantially
changed their behaviour during this wave
and since plan b
so the data show increased use of face
coverings in in crowded places people
are clearly using uh tests when they're
going to mix particularly with people
more vulnerable themselves than
themselves so people are assessing the
risk moving forward though we need to
recognize that we are now building up
immunity in the population both through
vaccination and through natural
infection what will be important in the
future is what other um whether other
variants emerge that are either have
caused more or less illness so we're
going to have to keep a close eye on
that but people have responded quite
substantially my concern now would be
going forward i mean
is we will see changes in behavior again
obviously as schools go back people
return to work so there'll be different
patterns of behavior and we'll have to
watch very carefully how much infection
goes on being transmitted but we also
need to think about how we most
effectively um
respond in terms of for example being
able to keep people at work and so on
uh of course i i've been saying this
morning covert is the big story in town
but um
i think it's probably wise not to forget
that there is such a thing as
conventional flu are you worried about
the impact of
uh flu this winter
well i'll just remind everybody that
every year we see flu being transmitted
in the population and very often the flu
the flu season if you like doesn't start
till the end of at the end of december
or going into january so um we there is
some there is but at the moment we have
very limited flu activity that doesn't
mean that we shouldn't see more what i
would emphasize is that we should
remember
that the pressures on the nhs are not
just a
coveted omicron there are also other
respiratory viruses which we see in
winter like respiratory incisional virus
and other viruses so people are in with
other other conditions as well
and we need to watch carefully for flu
two things are important that we've
already done to mitigate against that
first is that we've had a very good
vaccination program for flu this year
higher uptake it's been done along with
the boosters and secondly the behaviors
that people are changing to reduce risk
of transmitting covid will also limit
the transmission of other viruses like
flu and other respiratory viruses
daymen thank you so
much such a comprehensive briefing this
morning
thank you thank you
ow
brexit negotiations a phrase that's
supposed to be in the rear view mirror
by now well far from it the united
kingdom and the eu are still talking
about changes to the arrangements for
northern ireland and foreign secretary
liz trust is in the newspapers today
saying she's going to take unilateral
action and invoke article 16 to rip up
parts of the current agreement if they
can't find a new solution
so is there going to be a deal
and what happens if there isn't
the eu ambassador to the uk valley de
almeida joins me now
good morning uh mr valedian
um
do you think that there is a prospect
of
the article 15 being invoked by the
government uh soon
well good morning trevor or i should
rather say so trevor congratulations
uh
and and happy new year you're the first
of my guests to tease me about it this
morning but on the go well i think it's
well deserved well deserved and happy
new year to you and all the
all the viewers and our friends in the
united kingdom listen we heard this
before from the government so we are not
surprised we are not too impressed but
we still believe it's not very helpful
that we keep uh you know agitating the
issue of article 16. um
i think what we should focus on at least
that's where we are focused on is trying
to find solutions
for difficulties in the implementation
of the protocol but let me remind you uh
sir trevor of a very simple point
the problems arise and were
triggered by brexit not by the protocol
the protocol tries to mitigate the
serious problems created in northern
ireland by the brexit and the kind of
brexit that that was chosen so we are
focused on solutions
invoking article 16 or invoking issues
which are not the core concern of
citizens and business in northern
ireland and we have been listening to
them very attentively so doing article
16 or enlarging the scope of problems is
not going to contribute to find
solutions
by the way uh trevor is fine for this
program so trevor only happens when i
have my horse with me but just coming
back to the point in hand um
do you don't you think that uh
essentially the clock is ticking here
liz truss is going to meet the uh
leader in northern ireland to jeffrey
donaldson this week and at some point
soon we are going to have to have a
solution is it time for everybody to get
their skates on and start
bringing forth some new compromises
absolutely we we we need a new momentum
in these talks and we are eager to
reconnect with the british government
now with the foreign secretary and
looking forward to meetings
in a few days in in in britain and we
are eager to reconnect but we are even
more eager
to find compromises
because we need to move on it's been too
long
just to give you an example
we have listened attentively to sir
jeffrey and many other leaders uh to all
the leaders actually in northern ireland
we have engaged with the civil society
we have engaged with business my first
official visit out of london was to
northern ireland vice president
chevkovic with the interlocutor of least
trust has been there as well as in
constant contact we identified the
problems and in october we put forward a
very ambitious package of measures that
deals with all the main issues the core
concerns the difficulties in
implementing the protocol we now want
this to be fully discussed and i hope
that
at least we expect that from the british
government to reciprocate on our offer
of october and and get down to
concrete practical solutions that's
that's our spirit that's our approach
that's our mindset as we approach and we
prepare for the meetings in the in the
coming days
uh there of course is another um
event approaching that will put new
pressure on these negotiations and that
is uh that there will be elections to
the stormont assembly in may and in
practice
uh when this gets mixed up with
politics
does that is that likely to make the
negotiation even more complicated
i don't want to comment on the internal
situation of of a third country which i
when i proudly represent the european
union but i can tell you that we've been
we are in close contact with all the
political leaders in northern ireland
directly or or virtually on a very
regular basis and i think we fully
understand all the elements of the
complexity of the situation in northern
ireland the the european union has been
committed for a long time to peace and
prosperity in northern ireland we were
there since the beginning of the good
friday belfast agreement and we remain
absolutely committed to guarantee peace
and security and prosperity in northern
ireland and actually if i may trevor uh
highlight one point the protocol
provides a huge opportunity for northern
ireland just remember that this is the
only territory in the world that has
access to both the united kingdom market
but also to uh half a billion people
market which is the single market of the
european union so the only territory in
the world so this gives northern ireland
citizens not an island business a
perspective for job creation for foreign
investment for european investment but
also i understand canadian american
investors are very interested provided
we
guarantee that there is predictability
and security and stability in northern
ireland i think the protocol creates the
conditions for that against the
background of a brexit that created
enormous problems for northern ireland
we had to square the circle together
with our british friends it took a long
time now we have the protocol which is
international law british law eu law we
want to implement it with pragmatism
with a certain degree of flexibility
and that's what we're talking about and
that's what we should talk about in the
coming days and weeks and i share the
idea that we need a new momentum and i
hope that the meeting we're having in
chivening uh this week with the foreign
secretary will inject a new momentum
into these negotiations that's our hope
and that's our commitment
may i turn to a
rather different challenge uh to the eu
and foreign uh affairs and that is of
course
the fact that dozens of protesters and
12 police officers at least we think
have died in
ongoing violence in kazakhstan
russia has sent troops across the border
how worried is the eu about russian
incursion into its neighbors
well it's good that you mentioned russia
is good that you mentioned situation in
in kazakhstan because this is one area
of security in our neighborhood this is
one area where the eu and uk can do a
lot together and my my sense in looking
at the wider picture is that the sooner
we move on
from uh you know
issues that are still open related to
brexit in particular the north atlantic
situation the sooner we move on from
that
uh the better equipped we will be
the eu and the uk to work together in
addressing very serious
issues what can you do mr putin is not
um
mr putin
doesn't do much uh uh responding to warm
words does he i mean what can you
actually do to stop well i think
i think
you know i was in liverpool
in the in the g7 foreign affairs
ministers chaired by by lee strauss and
uh we together agreed a very strong uh
statement uh the european union member
states have a very common position of
strength the united states is together
the nato allies are together and we are
saying very clearly uh and these are
very clear words that there will be
massive consequences and severe cost if
russia
adventures into into ukraine with
military action
and and this is a very very solid and
unified position among ourselves as you
know today tomorrow the days after there
will be important diplomatic uh
initiatives taking place i forgive you
to interrupting the massive consequences
that's that's a good phrase would one
massive consequence be for the eu to say
to mr putin
if you keep on like this you can forget
about nordstrom 2 and that flow of
revenue from oil and gas into western
europe i don't think we should
anticipate action
we should react when action takes place
what we're doing now is trying to
de-escalate using all the diplomatic
tools and avenues that are available if
ever
russia moves into other direction
they can be sure that there will be a
unified response from our side and let
me give you this also as an example of
the need for us to move on in our
bilateral relationship because we are we
share the same values we share the same
strategic interests and there's a lot we
need to do regarding our neighborhood
but also regarding iran where we have a
very clear joint position with uk our
relationship with other parts of the
world thank you and the cooperation with
the u.s so it's a long list
and that is awaiting a better climate
ambassador thank you
ambassador thank you so much
now earlier this week four people were
cleared of criminal damage in a bristol
court wouldn't even made the pages
of the local paper most days but
much of the country saw videos of them
pulling down the statue of the slave
trader edward coulson in the city back
in june 2020.
now the attorney general says she might
refer the case to the court of appeal
and politicians of all persuasions have
been wading into the ongoing route
people we haven't heard much from are
bristolians themselves so let's put that
right now
the mayor of bristol marvin reese joins
me
um good morning mr mayor um
how significant
how significant is this case for bristol
well it depends on
your audience depends on your criteria
in the lives of the four individuals
it's incredibly significant uh you know
i guess because their
futures have just you know faced a bit
of a fork in the road in some ways uh
for the work on race inequality
in bristol uh much more widely it's less
significant
because uh you know my sense is that you
know when we're tackling race inequality
we're looking at those underlying
drivers of uh political and economic
inequality and and the verdict itself
doesn't actually touch on those uh very
real and immediate issues
so in essence you're saying this is
really
as far as bristol concerned a rather
marginal issue
well it it it would be noisy um but i'm
minded of a something someone said to me
the other day this too shall pass
i mean i you know it's it's one of the
warnings i make
all the time that we have to be careful
about symbolic acts and mere events
that's being substituted for acts of
real substantial systemic
change now make no mistake about it i
know i i don't like the idea of the
statue being up in the middle of the
city i'm glad it's not there um i think
that the debate around our history and
who we choose to celebrate as a country
is important these are symbols of
historical injustice and whose voice is
heard and i think there needs to be work
done on this and i would like to see
people who have been involved in
kidnapped rape and all the rest of it
not celebrated in public space but at
the same time symbolic acts
while they're important if they begin to
take the place of acts of political and
economic policy and real substance
become a problem because we look around
in five years realize that nothing's
really changed people point to all these
things that have happened and we say oh
but those were just acts those are just
performances so we have to be very
careful the way we uh we handle these
issues
is that a in a way another way of saying
what uh you said rather strikingly the
other day that people shouldn't come to
bristol in hope of fulfilling their
revolutionary fantasies um
the problem is you can't stop them can
you
no no but again there needs to be uh
what the fullness of what i said was if
they're coming to do real political
change to do some of the hard yards i
mean not all anti-racism work is done
with a banner and a t-shirt and a
megaphone right some of it's done by
looking at housing policy looking at
affordable homes looking at what we do
around making sure people are fed making
tweets to our mental health system
looking at the number of magistrates we
get and going out and recruiting stuff
that we've done over the last few years
that has not hit their headlines that
has not brought tens of thousands of
people onto the street but led just a
few years ago to
11 of 33 new magistrates in bristol
coming from black and asian backgrounds
that's never happened and yet we know
about the inequalities in the criminal
justice system uh you know that plague
and that's our central part of ongoing
racial inequality
so it's not all about what gets in the
headlines it's about sometimes those
those hard yards done in you know in
invisibility
well it's pretty clear what your what
your priority here is um
and
i just want to ask you this and
forgive me uh we we know each other uh
outside of this kind of encounter uh
let me ask you a direct question um as
the most senior elected black official
in the united kingdom
not if not in europe how do you feel
about um four white individuals claiming
to represent uh the feelings of minority
bristolians
well
well i i haven't poured over the things
they've been saying other than them and
their barristers saying that we've been
inactive in the city uh which obviously
i've you know got issues with and you
know and i'll be more than happy to talk
to them about what real
anti-racism uh work is i i as again i
think the symbolic acts are really
important and
you know they've played a part in
bristol's history but you're jumping off
my back here and then that takes us into
another realm of conversation more
broadly i think there is a question
about what it means to be an ally and
what allyship is um and you know trevor
i'm not over claiming my significance
but you know first black uh mayor in uk
probably the first black mayor of any
major european city there are challenges
if they are saying that racism is real
then surely they would also have enough
awareness to say there are probably some
issues about race that go with this
black guy becoming mayor you know of
bristol and we want to understand what
those are before we just railing and
start saying that nothing's happened in
the face of the reality that many things
have actually happened so so i i think
there are some layers to be uh to be
pulled back there that uh that would
actually present a bit of a teachable
moment for all parties concerned
marvin reece mayor of bristol thank you
very much indeed for your time this
morning
thank you
welcome to trevor phillips the take
where we look back at the morning's big
interviews and discuss what it all means
with our deputy political editor sam
coats uh let's get straight into it good
morning sam and happy new year to you
what uh did you make of what we heard
particularly from zawi
good morning trevor well it's worth just
pausing and reflecting isn't it just how
fast things are moving at the moment in
order to make sense of everything that's
going on
today it was barely more than a month
ago that we really first got to grips
with the existence of omicron and since
then boris johnson has had to introduce
more restrictions be urged by scientists
to go even further and start shutting
down
non-essential shops in england he
resisted and went into the christmas
break in a very perilous political
position
today we still have something like 146
000 people testing positive for
coronavirus that number peaking
record highs over the last 10 days or so
twice in the united kingdom more than
200 000 people a day getting omicron and
now we've got different signals
different pools uh politicians in london
facing and around the country what you
have at the moment is the government
having to tread very carefully because
it has been in such a rocky situation
confidence in boris johnson somewhat
shaken both having to deal with the
potential for an nhs crisis by the sheer
number of cases but huge political
pressure uh to start pulling back from
where we are uh in terms of coronavirus
measures that what was what has been
reflected uh this morning in your
conversations particularly with nadeem
zahawi how do cabinet ministers how does
boris johnson
manage the fact that there is still a
pandemic yet we do appear to be just
over the national peak if you look at
the graph of cases we're just starting
to go down
but numbers still going up outside
london how does he deal with that and
how much does he give in to his own
party that wants him to ease
restrictions
in so many different ways as quickly as
possible
well let's say we can get any signals
from that interview with education
secretary nadim zahawi uh in an
interview with the sunday times today
mrs ali said the country was moving from
pandemic to endemic
i asked him if this meant that the
isolation period could be reduced
further and where the free lateral flow
test could soon be a thing of the past
we have to be careful
um as to whether we move because what
you could end up as an is actually a
a perverse incentive where where the uh
spike
is higher because people come out of
isolation too early but they said they
will review it of course it would help
for that to happen as soon as possible
well i would
obviously always defer to the scientific
advice on this it would certainly um you
know help mitigate some of the pressures
on
schools on critical workforce and others
but i would absolutely be
um you know
driven by the advice from the experts
another uh suggestion that's uh
apparently coming forward and i think
you
are associated with this that um
lateral flow tests at some point gonna
have to stop being free
uh if this is a
an endemic condition
when do you want that to happen i saw
that story this morning which i was
slightly puzzled by because i don't
recognize that at all this is absolutely
not where we are at on the contrary i've
just said to you in my opening remarks
that you know for january alone we've
got 425 million lateral floaters coming
in and they'll continue to be uh
available for free because actually
we've got three lines of defense the
booster and obviously vaccination if you
haven't been vaccinated testing and
antivirals and all those three things
are really so i don't really recognize
where that story's coming to be clear
there are no plans at the moment
absolutely not to
stop lateral flow tests being free
absolutely not
well let's uh bring
back in our deputy political editor sam
coach sam um
he's pretty punchy there wasn't he
that's right and then i thought that
nazims whole we really encapsulated a
lot of the
government's dilemmas when it comes to
handling coronavirus
so take that first point that we were
that you were discussing whether or not
to move uh from a requirement that
people with omicron self-isolate for
seven days down to uh five days after
the us did it um nadine sahar were we
perfectly fairly making the point that
they measured this differently uh in the
u.s but not into his answer
i think tells you a lot about where the
conservative party is he personally
wants to do it he said i can see the
benefits and of course as education
secretary uh you might be able to get
more teachers back in classrooms you can
see the benefits uh for hospitals but he
said that the scientists are quite
strongly warning that it's quite hard to
go down the same path of the u.s because
uh in the uk you can start your clock
ticking the day that you get symptoms
and if you do this in the uk you could
just end up missing uh or allowing
people who are still infectious to go
back into classrooms into hospitals
and that would slow uh the path down
from the peak so that's the dilemma they
want to do it but the scientists are
flashing the red signal will it happen
hard to say but cabinet ministers going
on the record calling for it is a bit of
a moment but then you've got this
question about whether or not the
government are going to start
challenging
for lateral flow tests now again i was
absolutely fascinated by the way
nadim zahawi dealt with this this is the
story on the front page of today's
sunday times and nadine sahara has just
been on your show and said i don't
recognize this it's absolutely not what
we're planning
well up to a point lord copper in fact
uh nadine zahawa is almost faux outrage
about this story goes a bit too far yes
the government are planning it nadim
zahari is wrong to claim that there's
nothing uh in the government plans to
suggest this it's down in black and
white it's in the government's own covid
recovery plan just a few months ago they
wrote at a later stage the government's
response to the government's response to
the virus changes universal
free provision of lateral flow devices
will end and individuals and businesses
using the tests will bear the costs it
is only a question of timing i think
without omicron this may well have been
pretty imminent there is pressure from
the treasury because of the enormous
cost understandably of doing this so
nadine sahari i would dare to say simply
flat wrong to say that there are no
plans to do this the question is simply
when the government do that and it's
understandable that they don't want to
do it now
and the government and the opposition
labour are saying it would be
irresponsible to do it while omicron
cases uh are so high so i think uh i
think
there is the government is getting
themselves in a mess on this subject not
least because it looks like the sunday
times were sort of uh floating an idea
perhaps to test public opinion on it but
there are risks in doing that whoever
briefed the sunday times now has to
have on their conscience the fact that
many many people will see that story and
react completely naturally by running to
the nearest pharmacy and stocking up
because they'll be worried that suddenly
there might be a charge attached now
that quite frankly could be
irresponsible if the government or
whoever briefed the sunday times did so
without considering the real life
immediate consequences of such a story
well that shows that the government
isn't incapable of acts of self-harm
even in this new year
blimey sam well
frankly if uh ministers want to come
back and correct them correct themselves
sky news is always available um now i
also spoke to the first minister for
wales mark drakeford this morning the
welsh government's approach to the
handling of omicron variant has been in
stark contrast to that uh in england
with mr drakeford and his team
introducing restrictions to try and curb
cases so i asked him when he thought the
peak of this wave would be
and we're not at the top of that wave
yet but once we get to the top the
modelling shows a relatively rapid
decline from that peak as well
so as soon as we are in a position to
see the peak past and the position
improving of course we will want to
revert to the far the more modest level
of protections we had in place only a
few weeks ago
we're hopeful that the level of
protections we currently have in place
will be sufficient
to mitigate the impact of omicron to
help our nhs to deal with the
astonishing pressures which it's having
to deal with every day
and we announced on friday that the
current level of protections will remain
in place for the next week
uh let's bring back in deputy political
editors sam this this um
issue of the divergence between the
different centers of government united
kingdom becoming quite tasty isn't it
yes it's been one of the features of the
coronavares pandemic for the last uh two
years really um interestingly this all
comes from a decision very early on to
do quite a lot of uh the health
restrictions or the public health
restrictions using health legislation
rather than national security
legislation why does that matter because
it means that the devolved
administration's mart drake quits
government in wales nicholas sturgeons
in northern ireland and whatever form of
government we have in north uh scotland
and whatever form we have a government
in northern ireland can all go separate
ways to westminster and they have and
they do
and in many ways that's sensible one of
the fascinating things that we heard
this morning perhaps the thing that will
strike that will stay with me the most
from this morning's show
is that in a moment we'll hear from
kevin uh penton uh the public fentanyl
the public health director uh from
london saying look in london the public
the omicron wave has probably peaked and
possibly beat even uh on new year's eve
new year's day but you had mark
drakeford uh coming on your show and
saying look it's gonna be two weeks
before the peak has passed in wales and
only then when cases are coming down and
he said he hopes that they'll come down
there pretty rapidly only then can we
start to ease the more severe
restrictions uh in london uh sorry in
wales now why does this matter well it
matters in part because you do have
anomalies like the football club that
you were talking to mark drakeford about
which has the pitch in wales in england
but the offices in in wales effectively
stymied but uh unable to go ahead uh
with matches uh but it also matters
because there are some in the
conservative administration in
westminster looking to make political
capital out of boris johnson's decision
not to introduce further restrictions as
much as many and as tonic restrictions
as was the case in wales and scotland
just before christmas uh there are
limits on the number of people that can
gather outside in wales you can't for
instance do a park run something that
ministers in westminster have have
highlighted
and cabinet ministers do think that
boris johnson has some credit to be
earned certainly amongst english voters
by highlighting for political reasons
the differences uh between uh england
and wales
but mark drakeford's saying look i don't
think that having differences between
the two is a good idea but the peak is
at a different point and we're doing
what we think is right i think um this
isn't just a case of of public health uh
the differences between the nations have
become an issue of politics and at a
time where the united kingdom itself
feels somewhat fragile i think it's
really interesting to watch these
tensions playing out sam i i wanted to
uh just get your take on the economic
issues we discussed because i spoke to
the shadow chancellor rachel reeves who
set out labour's plan for a one-off tax
for an oil for oil and gas companies and
a corresponding tax cut on vat
i'm putting forward a one-off increase
in the taxes paid by north sea oil and
gas they are likely to make record
profits uh this year because of that
spike in prices but it is those on lower
incomes families and pensioners as well
as well as those who
the squeezed middle uh who are
struggling with those rising bills and
rising tax putting extra support through
the walms homes discount to ensure that
those people get the help that is needed
an extra 400 pounds off their bills from
april uh this year to help them through
this difficult time with the prices high
and you'll know trevor that the prime
minister was the biggest advocate for
cutting vat on gas and electricity bills
during the european referendum but now
when cutting those bills would make more
difference than ever the prime minister
says no well i say that bills can't be
paid on broken promises it is the poorer
households who spend a higher proportion
of their spending on gas and electricity
bills and that's particularly so for
pensioner households who are at home
more and need to keep their homes warm
so i don't buy this idea that cutting
vit is somehow a regressive policy
sam we've only got a few seconds left
but uh good move by labour or not
well i think they're looking to
grab the initiative on this cost of
living pressures is going to be the
story of 2022. you've got a rise in the
energy cap likes to be in the region of
600 pounds coming in uh in the spring
you've got the national insurance rises
coming up in the spring you've got
council tax rising in the spring i think
people are going to find 2022 uh very
very tough maybe vat cuts the answer
currently the conservative is rejecting
it because it also helps the well-off
and money is tight uh but i think we're
going to keep coming back to this
question with labour and primarily
conservative ministers having to really
examine what they can do what they can
afford to do it's not going to be easy
do you think that um just
okay we haven't got time apparently i'm
always interested what sam has to say
but unfortunately i've got time to hear
more of it that's it from trevor
phillips on sunday this morning
um stay with us uh on sky news for the
latest on covet as the united kingdom
passes the milestone of 150 000 deaths
since the beginning of the pandemic
and we're going to see you again next
week
this issue is not going to go away but i
think that we are going to be talking a
lot more about that last question the
economy the cost of living tax rises uh
national insurance and energy
more on politics uh
in the s in a week's time
and thank you very much to all our
guests this morning and especially of
course to sam coach for his uh
interpretation of the politics see you
next week